d'aéroport pour obtenir le retour des
écologistes ça traduit une chose ça
traduit le fait que ce dont le président
voulait je pense à nicolas hulot ou à
d'autres ont refusé de venir et qui
s'est retrouvé comme la presse le titre
ce matin avec beaucoup de cruauté mais
malheureusement avec un peu de justesse
à faire du bricolage en soi j'entends
que le référendum local peut être la
solution mais tout ça sent tellement
l'arrière cuisine électorale
quelle question quel périmètre s'il fait
le seuil de loi et la bretagne c'est
possible selon vous je ne crois pas
qu'on puisse organiser un référendum
dans deux régions un référendum local
par définition doit être organisée par
une collectivité locale
en fait je pense que tout ça ça s'est
joué hier après midi avec beaucoup
d'impréparation et donc que la question
de la collectivité qui va l'organiser de
la question elle n'est pas posé le
principe de libre administration des
collectivités fait que une collectivité
doit se saisir de sa main je pense
sincèrement qu'on est sur du bricolage
en tout cas il ya au moins une chose sur
lequel je partage totalement la position
du président de la république sait il
faut sortir de tout ça j'avais la
naïveté de penser que quand on élisait
quelqu'un a des responsabilités c'était
pour qu'il prenne des décisions